donna's with us in Detroit Michigan hey
Donna how are you good how about you
better than I deserve
what's up okay my husband and I are
going to be taking a financial piece
class I'm going to be signing up and
start September 15th right and I just
reading a little bit you said something
about snowballing and I'm just wondering
how would you do that when you could
basically make your minimum payments on
your credit cards
well you can't the first goal is to make
your payments you got to eat keep the
lights on
make your bills that's goal number one
but as you start getting your written
budget going and get the details laid
out on that and you start figuring out
okay we got to sell this thing we got to
have a garage sale we may have to take
an extra job as you start doing some
things like that to create some wiggle
room in the math then question number
one is what's the first thing we do with
that extra money once we've made all
over barely made all of our payments if
there's an extra $200 an extra hundred
dollars an extra $10 what are we going
to do with it well your first goal is
maybe step one and that's save a
thousand bucks okay that's your first
goal get your beginner starter emergency
fund and you throw everything at that
until you get that and then once you've
done that then you start your debt
snowball and your debt snowball meaning
that you you're going to list your debts
not counting your home smallest to
largest and you pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one and you
attack the little one and you work your
way up now uh what how much debt do you
have well just in credit card debt and
an equity loan 71,000 okay all right and
what is your home worth um with this
we're just trying to figure that out I
think about 210 okay and how much is
your first mortgage um around like one
hundred fifty eight thousand one hundred
and sixty eight or fifty eight a hundred
and sixty eight sixteen yeah on it okay
and then how much is the equity loan
twenty-five thousand okay and what's
your household income his is um about a
hundred and ten thousand okay do you
have an income um I'm trying I don't
have an education education so I'm
trying to go out there and clean houses
okay good for you good for you but for
now we got one hundred ten thousand
dollar income you got twenty five
thousand dollars in home equity loan and
how much credit card debt does that mean
you have that's seventy one thousand
seventy one was including the home
equity wasn't it yes okay so twenty five
off of that means we've got about 45 or
46 and credit cards does that sound
right yes okay what are you buying with
those what caused that big long story
our whole marriage fifteen years my
husband has a stunning problem
so from CDs and going out he doesn't
have a spending problem he just is a
spending problem would be a
psychological problem and you'd be
bankrupt after twenty years he has has a
no game plan he has no budget no limit
and he never says no to little stuff but
little stuff can mount up over twenty
years to forty six grand yeah now is he
going to the class with you yes he's
planning on it as long as he doesn't
have to travel good well you get CDs in
the kit as you know and while he's
traveling if he's not in the class he's
listening to the CD okay and you join up
in Financial Peace University Central
and which is our compute you know you
hook up online with us as well when
you're in the class and you can go back
and re-watch if you need to rewatch a
lesson so he can get access to the
material even if he's on the road he
needs to do it with you that's very very
important okay don't let him up don't
let him off the hook because he'll plan
a trip every night there's a class if
you're not careful yeah no I don't think
that I think he's pretty good okay good
so because once you guys get on a plane
you're not buying anymore CDs you're not
going out tonight you're not going on
vacation
no we we've cut that out they're not
going to have a life until you get to
mess cleaned up I know and I'm a nervous
wreck
well you're gonna get it cleaned up you
the numbers you're giving me are doable
but you're gonna have to really cut your
lifestyle down to scorched earth nothing
bare-bones
beans and rice rice and beans and then
you start knocking off some of those
credit cards now you get all those
credit cards out and cut it you can go
ahead and cut them up for class starts
if you want okay we already did that all
right well you're on track
you're making decisions you're thinking
right as we lay it all out you're going
to find room in your budget to do these
things and I think you can pay off the
home equity loan and the credit card
debt 71,000 making 110 in about two
years but you're going to have no life
during that two years it's going to be
an awful two years it's going to be a
glorious two years because you're going
to change your whole freakin life this
is the Dave Ramsey show
you